[Music]
he's been called the most powerful
conservative voice in america watched by
millions every night and like me he's a
sworn enemy of censorship and a staunch
defender a free speech and tucker
carlson i'm glad to say he joins me now
tucker i've been on your show many times
finally i get you to come on as a guest
on my show i am honored thank you
well i ran to the camera i am so glad to
see you doing this and i was really
really happy to see the sharon osborne
interview which i just listened to
through my earpiece um thank you for for
talking to her i'm i'm glad she's back
of all the people i have seen censored
and bounced out of their jobs over the
past year it happened to her with less
justification than i've ever seen i i
never even understood what her crime was
well her crime it turned out was that
she simply endorsed my right to have an
opinion so when i had to leave the
morning show over here in the uk because
i didn't believe meghan markle who
turned out to be saying a lot of things
that weren't true
when i was kicked out of that job sharon
went on twitter and said i was entitled
to my opinion and for that she was
accused of supporting a racist because i
must be racist because i didn't believe
meghan markle had to do with her skin
color apparently and sharon has been
accused of being a racist sympathizer so
the whole thing i thought perfectly
exemplified the hysteria of this council
culture and how disingenuous the whole
thing is but also
in terms of what happened to sharon how
unbelievably destructive it can be if
you're in the firing line of this stuff
her life was really pretty well ruined
for a year
yes
so you're not allowed to express
skepticism about the public statements
of one of the most powerful people in
the world and sharon osborne is not
allowed to affirm your right to express
that skepticism and both of you get
fired for it so that's commentary on the
society that allows that to happen i
mean that's the definition of tyranny of
societal collapse like that's insane
that's the kind of thing that if it
happened in north korea we'd be like
well that's you know that's the society
we need to oppose
and this is happening in two of the free
societies in the world so um yeah i
don't think we're being hysterical when
we say
this is the main threat that all of us
face and what is extraordinary to me is
they they profess to be liberals these
sort of ultra woke council culture mob
people uh basically liberal about i mean
liberalism to me means that you you know
you believe in in democracy you believe
in free speech you believe in the fair
exchange of views you tolerate other
people's opinions they don't do any of
those things they behave it ironically
they behave like the very fascists they
claim to hate most
well of course and i i always think of
myself as a liberal i believe
fully and completely in free speech in
freedom of conscience
i am horrified by violence even
state-sponsored violence
i even like organic peanut butter so
to have these people
telling me that we should throw anyone
who disagrees with them out of work or
into prison have them call themselves
liberal talk about a perversion of the
word
it's preposterous now i'm sure it hasn't
escaped you'll notice i interviewed
president trump
ex-president trump i guess um i want to
play you a clip and what do you say when
i asked him the big question everyone's
sort of toying with is he gonna run
again listen to what he said
so here's the big question for you
which everybody wants to know the latest
poll says if the 2024 election was held
tomorrow you would beat joe biden by six
points and karma harris by 11 points in
other words you would be re-elected
president of the united states so are
you going to run again well you know for
reasons of campaign finance and
everything i'm not allowed to say but
let me just say this i think a lot of
people are going to be very happy
do you want me i i love our country our
country is going to hell i think a lot
of people are going to be very happy are
you going to run i'm not going to say
that but i think people are going to be
happy you might even be happy
what did you make of that tucker do you
think he's going to run again and i
suppose i got to ask you would you like
him to run again is it healthy for
america for the republican party how do
you see the way things are shaping up
here
what's healthy is for america or any
country great britain to be able to
choose its own leaders when the public
gets to decide by majority vote so i'm
just for democracy period i would say in
the case of trump i think he does love
america i think he sincerely believes
the election was stolen from him i don't
think he's just saying that he really
thinks that whether you agree with him
or not whether you think he should be
able to say that or not he really does
believe that um and i think he would
like to be vindicated in that belief and
maybe running again would be one way to
do it i personally and he hasn't said
this to me
you know i'm not an advisor to trump
hardly but i i actually don't think he
wants to be president again that's my
view
you know he's got a happy life um
he
affects you know american politics a lot
in his endorsements and i think
all things being equal he'd rather do
that and there are other people who
would like to run and you know i i
personally don't think he's gonna run
again i'm basing that on
no evidence whatsoever just a gut
feeling um and i'm i'm often wrong i
could be wrong again but that that's my
view now you talk about other people who
may be considering running you yesterday
got put in the frame because you
apparently gonna go and speak in iowa
always a sign that potentially someone
may be thinking of a career outside
cable news you are uniquely popular now
with the conservative base let me ask
you directly tucker carlson do you have
a plan to run for president
our show is popular
for the moment i've had a lot of shows
like you have sometimes they're popular
sometimes they're not
you know i've been fired for low ratings
so i've seen both sides of that um
and but that doesn't mean you know i've
never been in politics i've never been
elected you know room mother
um i'm not sure i have political skills
i will give a speech to anybody anytime
i'm really interested in what the
republican party becomes because it is
the the alternative to what we're seeing
now the neoliberalism of joe biden which
i don't think works i don't think is
popular and so i'm interested in seeing
the people who want to replace him
and some of them seem legitimate others
seem you know loathsome to be totally
honest so you know i
that's the reason i'm going is i want to
see these people and i want to talk to
them and i want to talk about them one
of the fascinating stories in the news
at the moment i know is particularly
relevant to you because you bounced back
on twitter yesterday with the words
we're back uh which is very exciting for
those of us who like your twitter feed
but elon musk and you know in my view
this extraordinary sort of maverick
billionaire genius rampaging around now
doing all this wildly exciting stuff
he is a big supporter of free speech and
what he believes it really means
what do you think of milan musk taking
over twitter and in particular when i
put it to trump for example that i felt
he was on a better a better hill to
fight on about a stolen election was
what happened with the new york post
story about hunter biden and the laptop
which was suppressed by big tech media
suppressed by mainstream media and could
have swung the election we just will
never know now but what do you think
about
him taking over twitter and his absolute
staunch defense of free speech this must
be a good thing right
well i think it's a deal killer for the
people in charge i mean why has this
elicited the levels of hysteria that it
has i mean the byte administration
immediately announced a federal
investigation into musk's other
businesses so it tells you they'll
destroy him before they allow this who
will win i don't know
but they understand that social media
are central to their rule
like people who are legitimately running
things don't need to lie or prevent
prevent you from expressing your opinion
they're comfortable with free speech but
people who aren't have to censor you or
they lose control so they see this as an
existential argument as for
musk i mean if he takes over twitter and
opens it up to true free speech where
american citizens can say what they
think about their country he will be a
hero a historic hero
it's kind of pathetic however that we
need him yeah we need some billionaire
that we're waiting for dad to come back
and rescue us we have a political system
that's based on the bill of rights and
the first line in that the first
amendment is freedom of speech and our
political system can't seem to guarantee
that so we are left waiting for the
world's richest man to restore to us
what we were born with which is our
right to give our opinion and there's
something very depressing about that but
i'm still
thrilled that musk is doing it it's an
extraordinary state of affairs uh i
could talk to you for hours
unfortunately run out of time thank you
for joining me in my launch week i
greatly appreciate it and it's great to
be working with you
i'm
well i'm just grateful that you're back
uh well deserved one of the one of the
one of the big talents in television so
thank you for having me tucker really
appreciate it thank you very much indeed